[Música]
o kit move o que te inquieta de tira o
sono que convoca para a vida o que
instala a urgência da ação em você eu
descobri o que move no dia em que tudo
parou
minha filha alice que havia nascido
prematura estava internada há mais ou
menos um mês em uma uti neonatal teve
uma parada cardiorrespiratória que durou
26 minutos
naquele momento tudo parou tudo suspenso
só uma urgência gritava dentro de mim
a urgência da vida aquela parada se
tornou um diagnóstico de paralisia
paralisia cerebral
os médicos nos diziam de muitas
impossibilidades não falar não sentar
não andar ali senão teria uma vida
independente e para cada anúncio do que
não aconteceria nos diziam da
necessidade de buscarmos recursos
devemos oferecer medicamentos terapias e
tratamentos
tudo que desce ao seu cérebro a
oportunidade de se reconfigurar naquilo
que é conhecido como plasticidade
cerebral
foi isso que fizemos o primeiro ano da
alice foi uma corrida insana em torno de
tratamentos pesquisávamos todas as
notícias em busca de qualquer
possibilidade que pudesse curá la ou
melhorar a sua condição
enquanto ela cumpre uma agenda pesada de
terapias
muitas vezes ela fazia sessões dormindo
porque ainda era um bebê e tomava fortes
medicações para convulsão bom aqui
aquele momento em que se espera que eu
diga que todo esse esforço valeu a pena
e que alice 8 criança linda
dela com seis anos que corre pra todo
lado porque é isso o que se espera de
uma pessoa com deficiência que ela
supere a sua condição mas a nossa
realidade é outra e o que eu acredito
que tem ser superado também alice
continua sem sentar sem falar sem andar
sem fazer nenhuma atividade com
autonomia
eu também sei se um dia ela para essas
coisas
isso deixou de ser importante diz pouco
sobre ela
minha filha é sim uma criança linda e
também valente e corajosa bem à morada
que tem amigos que adoram ouvir música e
que até rebola na cadeira de rodas é uma
criança como é grande em faro mas não
vai ver a igreja
com que é que a creche irmã
mas toda essa alegria e essa
possibilidade de ver quem ela é também
foi uma conquista
o que tem que ser superado não está na
lista não está na deficiência o que tem
que ser superado não está em nenhuma
característica do nosso corpo
a deficiência é parte da experiência
humana não tem que ser eliminada e
também não pressupõe sofrimento
o que tem que ser superado está nas
nossas relações com o outro e com o
mundo
o que tem que ser consertado são os
lugares sem acessibilidade às
tecnologias que não estão a serviço de
todas as pessoas
o currículo escolar que não valoriza o
que cada aluno é as coisas aqui deveriam
se ajustar as pessoas não o contrário
passar a vida acreditando que pra ser
feliz para ter respeito é preciso andar
falar e ter o corpo dentro de
determinada norma é uma vila é violência
não há outro nome para isso a gente não
tem padrão gente é única
o lar inexata inacabada gente é uma
delícia porque é justamente assim o
mistério e descoberta
nossa urgência no mundo deveria ser
criar condições para que todos possamos
ser quem somos autênticos
o problema é que muitas vezes somos
pressiona a nada
a seguir padrões padrões e nos fazem
sangrar
é preciso dedicar tempo as reflexões
necessárias
que padrões são esses a quem eles servem
em que medida o que querem enquadrar
ajustar ao era quem eu sou
há inúmeras nuances entre buscar
recursos que contribuem para a qualidade
de vida e tentar assim está em um padrão
pra ser feliz
para ter acesso a oportunidades em
última instância para ter direito a ave
compreender isso é conhecer as
engrenagens que nos oprimem o direito de
ser diferente é uma conquista de área é
preciso desafiar esses padrões que
insistem nos reduzir que maltratam que
sufoca a vida que fazem com que o sol na
meia dúzia de pessoas no crime com isso
a experiência humana é sobre pertencer
não sobre cabelo e antes que se possa
pertencer ao mundo é preciso que se
possa pertencer ao próprio corpo
através dele celebrar as diferenças
experimentar outros caminhos de
alteridade de respeito de criatividade
de afeto de paz quando as diferenças que
nos distinguem que nos fazem únicos
resulta em desvantagens
assim um adoecimento a ser curado
o da nossa consciência o da cultura e do
sistema em que estamos inseridos
é preciso curar o preconceito é o
preconceito que limita o que afasta que
julga que fere que silencia que mata o
preconceito é feito água parada
inerte ocioso
ga propício indesejável e ferramenta
indispensável para a perpetuação de
injustiça e preconceito nos autoriza a
hierarquizar as vidas essa a dentro dos
padrões
essa precisa ser consertada essa é
descartável
foi ele o preconceito que me levou pelos
primeiros caminhos em torno da minha
filha alice e é interessante porque o
preconceito é um sentimento tão ardiloso
tão persistente que não se incomodou de
andar de mãos dadas com aquilo que é o
meu maior amor
muitas vezes eu achei que estava
demonstrando afeto mas estava rebolando
preconceito ou capacity zta que é o
preconceito em relação às pessoas com
deficiência
perdão
[Aplausos]
foram esses os caminhos que eu percorri
os primeiros momentos da minha filha
alice o que move a vida é a diversidade
é ela que nos coloca em movimento que
interdita o caminho do óbvio e que nos
atira as descobertas
é ela que nos apresenta novas
perspectivas diferentes maneiras de ser
e estar no mundo
ora não somos gregários nós precisamos
do outro para evoluir
precisamos de cada um
para a nossa sorte a diversidade a
matriz da nossa existência
na natureza produzem números a ajustes
entre plantas e animais planetas e
universos na humanidade abre espaço para
infinitos arranjos de existir e de
experimentar felicidade compreender isso
é afastar a idéia do ser humano como uma
categoria uma coisa e entendê lo como um
ato contínuo uma ponte
passei a pensar grande e fiz da escrita
uma aliada importante nesse processo de
assumir a urgência ea responsabilidade
de participar do mundo
foi assim que nasceu o diário da mãe da
alícia pra mim ainda não inventaram
armas mais poderosas do que as palavras
e é por isso que eu escrevo palavra que
principia a ação
escrevo escrevo
e vivo faço do encontro com cada pessoa
uma oportunidade de ventilar outro mundo
possível
pode ser com uma pessoa com dezenas com
centenas delas não importa fazer a
inclusão acontecer é muito mais do que
garantir elevadores rampas braille
libras cada um desses recursos partiu de
uma intenção e aí é preciso perguntar o
que move um prefeito a construir um
parquinho acessível em sua cidade
o que move um arquiteto a projetar um
espaço em que todos tenham lugar o que
move um motorista de ônibus
a fácil para o embarque e desembarque de
todos os passageiros
o que faz com que o cidadão queira
conviver com o outro
de outro modo o que faz com que a falta
de acessibilidade ainda seja algo tão
aceitável e uma cadeira de rodas produza
tanto estranhamento fazer a inclusão
acontecer é rever conceitos
educar consciência transformar atitudes
é muito mais do que fazer o que é certo
e garantir direitos ressoar a
diversidade humana como a nossa maior
riqueza ea inclusão como uma necessidade
comum de todos nós sempre deixamos que a
verdade seja nossa professora
não podemos privar as pessoas de uma
convivência inclusiva e acolhedora da
experiência humana é nisso que eu
acredito
o que move a vida é a diversidade
o que nos tira do lugar comum o que nos
apresenta possibilidades
o mundo não é o lugar só de uma minoria
branca heterossexual masculina sem
deficiência
há muito muito muito mais que nos escapa
não somos mais de sete milhões de
pessoas no mundo e não há ninguém igual
a ninguém
deixemos que a diversidade oxigênio as
nossas afirmativas apresente novas
perspectivas concilie ir com o que há de
melhor em nós que ela seja como chuva
fina na água parada do preconceito
a gente vai se permitindo acessar a
história do outro o jeito de ser aquilo
que parece esquisito e com isso vai
ampliando o repertório para entender o
outro ea si mesmo é que a vida é feito
rio fluidez e atrevimento e tentar
conter o rio ururaí estrutura de
paradigmas e preconceitos é conter uma
energia colossal de possibilidades que
nos atravessam por todos os lados por
todos os poros todos os dias
o convite é para abrir o peito deixar
areja para que a humanidade tem espaço
aqui dentro
pela fé e lá fora pela sua atitude
esteja atento e disposto a esse
movimento
faça esse movimento seja esse movimento
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]
[Música]